bleibt dran wenn ihr wissen möchte wie
man diese ultra fluffige und wolken
welche biskuitrolle mit erdbeeren macht
für den tiger wasser zucker und vanille
extrakt drei minuten lang mixen dann
mehl und backpulver zu sehen kurz
unterrühren und auf einem backblech
verstreichen nach dem backen dann
vollständig auskühlen lassen ich hab
hier tobt in puderzucker außerdem gp
obendrüber noch ein feuchtes
küchenpapier die creme besteht aus sahne
vanille extrakt zucker und sahne fest
und zum schluss gehen wir noch
magerquark mit dazu und außerdem
abgeriebene bio zitronenschale die
kleben verstreichen wir dann auf den
abgekühlten bis geboten schöne frische
erdbeeren noch oben drüber und das ganze
einräumen ich hab das über nacht in den
kühlschrank gegeben aber zwei stunden
reichen auch vollkommen aus und fertig
ist die fluffige bis kontrolle